deadly stunts an obsessed Beetle and a
game-changing mission to Mars This is
the incredible story of 2001 A Space
Odyssey throughout his career Stanley
Kubrick clearly enjoyed adapting novels
into movies he drew on Source material
ranging from pop fiction such as Stephen
King's The Shining to more serious
literary fare like Vladimir nabokov's
Lolita like many of Kubrick's other
works 2001 is based on a book unlike the
other adaptations however the
novelization of 2001 was written
alongside the film's production inspired
to write a movie about space travel and
all its possibilities Kubrick decided to
work with the legendary sci-fi author
Arthur C Clarke the two men agreed to
work together on a story which clock
would turn into a novel while Kubrick
made it into a movie while both Clark
and Kubrick were creative Geniuses in
their own right they had a hard time
actually finishing the film's official
screenplay according to a 1966 New
Yorker profile on the making of 2001
Kubrick estimated that he and Clark
spent an average of four hours a day six
days a week writing the script however
the film's release was delayed until
1968 as some of the plot's finer details
had to be worked out on set whether or
not there was a definitive method to
their Madness Kubrick Clark and Company
wound up with one of Cinema's most
enduring sci-fi stories
The Narrative thrust behind 2001 is the
idea that sooner or later humans are
going to have a close encounter of the
Third Kind it was a timely concept to
explore as during the movie's early
production stages in 1964 a NASA space
probe named the Mariner 4 was on its way
past Mars Kubrick was so confident the
discovery of extraterrestrial life was
imminent he began to fret that NASA
would encounter something on the red
planet before his movie was finished
worried at the possibility of losing
creative license on a story about NASA
Pilots meeting alien intelligence in
deep space Kubrick decided to check if
he could take out an insurance policy on
his own story somehow Kubrick actually
found a company that would offer him
insurance and so he bought the policy
despite its Galactic price tag while the
human race is apparently yet to meet
extraterrestrials it's safe to say that
Kubrick was most definitely a believer
Kubrick found his first hit directing
1960s historical epic Spartacus he
followed that success with a black
comedy about the existential threat born
from the nuclear arms race Dr
Strangelove the kneeless classic is a
hilarious yet devastating satire that's
often imitated but has never been truly
matched I don't know if you can't fight
in here this is the War Room Kubrick had
been inspired to make Dr Strangelove
after researching nuclear defense
policies and taking them to their
logical Extremes in his 1966 New Yorker
profile on Kubrick Jeremy Bernstein
quotes the director is saying the
nuclear strategists who make up all
those War scenarios are never as
inventive as reality and political and
military leaders are never as
sophisticated as they think they are
Bleak stuff for sure but it's entirely
in line with the central thesis of
doctor Strangelove however Bernstein
argued that Kubrick found what he
referred to as limited optimism in the
Space Race Kubrick apparently felt that
the opportunities presented by space
exploration and alien contact just might
save the human species from itself his
belief in the power of space exploration
is all over 2001 from its beautiful
soundtrack to its depiction of man's
divorce from Earthbound technology
Kubrick clearly thought that Mankind's
Ventures into space were full of
potential depicting the future on screen
is no easy feat in order to create a
future audiences may find plausible
Kubrick formed a think tank consisting
of 35 artists and designers a special
effects team more than 20 strong and
several Consulting scientific advisors
this platoon of forward thinkers worked
to ensure the designs of everything felt
futuristic in a believable Way by most
accounts it's fair to say they succeeded
the film's aesthetic is stunning and
some of the choices made by Kubrick and
his design crew are still popular to
this day take for example the movie's
use of RNA Jacobson's flatware a brand
made famous by 2001 that is still bought
and sold today clearly Kubrick's
attention to detail paid dividends while
many film goers may not remember a full
detailed play-by-play of the movie
sprawling plot they'll likely remember
the Innovative aesthetic who were
curated to bring his vision to life one
of the most iconic designs in 2001 is
the Discovery one the NASA exploratory
vessel headed to Jupiter in search of an
alien radio signal in the film Kubrick
handles the spacecraft's introduction
with a level of care usually reserved
for human protagonists its Grand Design
fills the screen as it drifts slowly
into frame then the movie shows off the
ship's distinctive interior a centrifuge
decorated with beds workstations a
dining table computers and more Kubrick
and his advisors felt that long voyages
through space would require artificial
gravity to keep astronauts healthy many
including Kubrick also agreed that
gravity could be easily created in space
with the aid of a centrifuge so the
director hired an engineering company to
build one inside the giant centrifuge
the technology of space flight is seen
at close range the finished product
could spin up to 3 miles an hour cost
three hundred thousand dollars and came
in at about 38 feet in diameter the end
result is not only one of the most
Innovative sets ever designed but a
wonderful symbol for Kubrick's ultimate
Vision like 2001 itself the centrifuge
set is large expensive and very hard to
forget
in one of the film's most thrilling
sequences Dave Bowman finds himself
locked outside of the discovery 1 in a
small maintenance pop Bowman considers
leaving his pod space walking to the
main ship and climbing back inside but
he doesn't have his helmet to get back
into the Ship Without suffocating in
space Bowman fires himself through the
pod's escape hatch into an open airlock
it's an ingenious scene that only runs
about 90 seconds in total in fact the
shot of Bowman launching into the open
airlock is even shorter but that single
shot was extremely dangerous actor care
delay had to dive head first through
Breakaway boards from a platform two
stories above the airlock set falling
down toward an upward tilted camera to
convincingly create the illusion that he
was launching through weightless space
for safety he was secured with a single
rope connected to a pulley an enormous
film camera was positioned at the bottom
of the airlock set to capture the image
in a single take if something had gone
wrong dulay would have crashed directly
into the camera and likely been killed
in the process delay later told Vanity
Fair I think that was the only time on
2001 I got something on the first take
thank God
the dawn of man sequence that kicks off
2001 may be one of the boldest openings
ever depicted in a science fiction movie
in a wordless 10-minute sequence Kubrick
and Company recreate primordial Earth to
present the concept of extraterrestrial
beings jump starting the evolution from
ape to human famously the end of the
sequence season 8 tossing a bone into
the air which slowly transforms into a
satellite orbiting Earth Kubrick
originally tried to film the sequence on
location in Africa but eventually wound
up creating the set in a sound stage in
Britain with a technique known as front
projection the burgeon and camera system
allowed creatives to project
photographic Vistas directly into their
shot however new cameras weren't the
only trick up Kubrick's sleeve the
design team were also tasked with
designing costumes for the Apes despite
their best efforts the sequence went
largely ignored come award season
somewhat ironically the best costume
design Oscar went to Planet of the Apes
damn you thank you
oh God damn you hold the hell while 2001
became the biggest box office earner of
the year when it was released in 1968
MGM took quite a leap of faith when they
originally decided to back Kubrick's
project Kubrick first sent MGM Arthur
Clark's 250-page draft narrative rather
than a finished screenplay and yet
Studio president Robert O'Brien still
agreed to back the filmmaker's vision
given the film's many delays it's safe
to assume O'Brien's confidence may have
been tested along the way mgm's original
press release for the film claimed that
2001 was to be ready for release by
1966. the movie was delayed until 1968
and in 66 the movie's budget increased
from 6 million to 7 million dollars in
the end the film cost MGM around 10
million dollars almost double its
initial budget even though the film
eventually found success over the course
of its release year The Saga concluded
with a shareholder volt according to the
New York Times MGM was also making
another expensive film Dr Zhivago around
the same time with the company facing
such a financially uncertain future
O'Brien wound up resigning as president
in 1969. even though 2001 is widely
regarded as a stone cold classic today
initial reactions from movie critics
were not particularly kind legendary
movie critic Pauline kale said the film
was ponderous and blurry in her review
for Harpers in the New York Times critic
Renata Adler said the movie's
uncompromising slowness rendered the
film hard to sit through without talking
well I don't think there is any question
about it
it can only be attributable to human
error Kubrick was clearly bothered by
the early negative press in a 1968
interview with Playboy the director
expressed his annoyance insisting that
only New York had really been hostile to
the movie he went on to blame the
sensibilities of a cohort he referred to
as New York City's lump in Literati for
their own aversion to his movie since
the expression of grandeur and Cosmic
Wonder while 2001 certainly marches to
its own deliberate Pace it's safe to say
that the movie has aged much better than
its initial reviews today for example it
holds a top 20 spot on the American Film
institute's 100 greatest American films
of all time list
2001 may not have been an immediate hit
with the critics but it very quickly
gained cult status with hippies in fact
the movie was so popular with pillars of
the 60s counterculture community that
the new yorker's 50th Anniversary
retrospective argues that it may have
been a hippie audience that saved the
film from obscurity supposedly fans of
the film consumed psychedelic drugs in
sync with Dave Bowman's trip through the
colorful chaotic Wormhole at the climax
of the film mgm's marketing gurus
eventually got wind of the phenomenon
and added a new tagline to posters the
ultimate trip but word of mouth and
ultimate trips weren't the only thing
bolstering the film's popularity it also
received endorsement from Rock Legends
such as David Bowie and John Lennon
Lennon specifically liked it so much
that he claimed to have seen it every
week during its initial theatrical run
2001 didn't just inspire a generation of
film goers to look up to the stars and
wonder about the future it also inspired
tons of today's best filmmakers for the
movie's 50th Anniversary Indie wire
collected thoughts from a collection of
famous filmmakers on Kubrick's Master
entry to the Sci-Fi Canon the list
featured praise from directors including
Steven Spielberg Claire Dany Christopher
Nolan James Cameron George Lucas Ridley
Scott and Alfonso coron film fans may
not be particularly surprised by this
collection of acolytes as Kubrick's
lasting impact on the industry cannot be
undersold however the impact of 2001
lives on outside of the elite of
Blockbuster filmmakers a 50th
Anniversary retrospective and vulture
credits the film for opening up
possibilities for headier more complex
sci-fi in the Indie realm on top of that
any sci-fi movie about nefarious
artificial intelligence made since 1968
owes a serious debt to the original
murderous computer Hal 9000. open the
pod bay doors hell
I'm sorry Dave I'm afraid I can't do
that clearly Kubrick went on an odyssey
of his own to get 2001 made and perfect
his vision in the end though he
introduced audiences to a whole new
cosmic possibilities at the movies and
Beyond